is difficult to not smile when you see
just how happy ukrainians are
particularly those who live in kazano
are finally being liberated
um we've not talked about what this
means for Russia have we um what is your
take on it yeah first of all it's
fantastic to see these scenes it's a
decisive Victory it's the only Regional
Capital that Russia had ever taken and
it's badly liberated after eight or nine
months in their hands a massive setback
however you play it for Russia Ukraine's
still got to deal with booby traps
there's also reports of lots of Rogue
Russian forces that were left behind
who've got into civilian clothing
they'll create a problem likewise the
karkov KA Dam here we've always we were
it was mine by the Russians if they did
decide to blow that that could cause a
lot of problem uh for for the ukrainians
but um no fantastic Euphoria it's worth
actually pointing out from a military
perspective though
um this probably this would draw
probably suited both sides both Ukraine
and Russia which is a odd thing to say
given a withdrawal looks like defeat
doesn't it looks like they're they're
running over the river with the tail
between their legs yeah but part of this
is from a military perspective you want
to focus on your main efforts and it's
pretty clear that the Russian strategy
their main effort is up here in the
donbass they've been throwing lots and
lots of forces the one area of the
donbass that they don't currently own
they've been taking huge casualties with
inexperienced soldiers so actually
withdrawing from Harrison in orderly
manner with their equipment redeploying
their forces up to the donbass will
allow them to re-reattack up there with
30 000 more soldiers which will make
life very very difficult uh from from
Ukraine perspective likewise from um
From zelenski's perspective he his main
effort was almost certainly has some and
he's managed to retake that without
having to fight his way in it's worth
pointing out that this is not a route if
you remember upper car key when the rush
the ukrainians pushed the Russian forces
back and then chase them down the road
and they took out vast ways of territory
having a house and because the the
ukrainians have taken out many of the
bridges but the denit pro is now a very
effective barrier and the Russians have
also dug in defensively on the far side
so it will not be easy for Ukraine to
chase the Russian forces out well it
looks very likely at the moment the
Russian priority is going to be the
donbass protect the land bridge down to
Crimea and potentially then achieve
success with its special Mercury
operation so what happens next
you've got winter arriving which
generally slows things down
um both sides are running shorter
weapons at the moment and both sides
will be battle weary from a Russian
perspective their military is spent at
the moment they're also running shorts
of weapons they're going to Iran to try
and get drones and cruise missiles he's
pretty close to achieving his objectives
here and he's got a bit of an uprising
back domestically so actually it's
almost certain Putin's getting close to
the point where he would be prepared to
negotiate from a Ukrainian perspective
though their tails are up their morale
is high and as you've heard they're
trying to get rid of all Russian forces
from everywhere including Crimea part of
the challenge with that though is a bit
of realism they're also short of weapons
the West is supplying those weapons but
they're coming they can't be brought to
the supermarket they're coming from war
stocks and those War stocks are running
low so there's a limit to how far that
can go and Crimea is an interesting case
Russia
um over 200 years ago spent a lot of
love and treasure to seize Crimea that
has withstood attacks of armies in the
second world world war that will it's
very well fortified and it will not be
easy for Ukraine to take that without a
fight from a military perspective the
military always fight these battles but
it's the political end that ends up
resolving them and every second this
goes on more and more soldiers die tens
of thousands have gone already we're not
at the end yet but we're going to see
increasing International pressure
particularly from America for president
zielinski to start at least picking up
the phone okay watch this space Sean for
now thank you very much